there's a power the executive the
legislative and the judicial branches of
government that had created powerful
systems of indoctrination through
Christian radio and television and
Christian schools and I think in a
period of instability whether that's
caused by an economic meltdown or
another catastrophic terrorist attack I
spent a year of my life by the way
covering al-qaeda
out of Paris for the New York Times and
there wasn't an intelligence chief that
I interviewed who used the word if was
always when I think this movement
combined with forces anti-democratic
forces that have been empowered by this
administration could radically reshape
American ways that we've not seen since
the nation's founding all of that is by
way of saying that I take the rise of
religious extremism and Christian
fundamentalism in this country very very
seriously movements that fuse the
iconography and language of religion
with the iconography and language of
nationalism something that I saw in the
former Yugoslavia covers the balkan
bureau chief therefore the New York
Times during the war is toxic and
extremely dangerous
and proto-fascist following this book I
was invited in May of last year to Royce
hall at UCLA to debate Sam Harris author
of the end of faith and led her to a
Christian nation and two days later flew
to San Francisco and went to Berkeley to
debate Christopher Hitchens not an
experience I'd wish on anyone in this
room author of God is not great now any
serious student of theology cannot have
a complete education without paying
homage to the importance of atheism in
the Western intellectual tradition first
of all most of the great philosophical
and theological
reformers were condemned in their day as
atheists and heretics one thinks of
Spinoza or even Martin Luther I don't
think anyone who has a complete
education in theology can ignore the
wisdom and I'm Fredrick Nietzsche I mean
he was also insane but there were parts
of him that were brilliant he certainly
understood the consequences of a culture
where God was dead the kind of moral
nihilism and the will to power that I
think have very much come to
characterize the ethos of modern society
a writer such as Sartre and Camus are
serious and should be taken seriously
and heated for their deep insights into
the human condition so actually came
towards these new atheist fairly
predisposed to accept the tradition that
they said they represented upon reading
their works however and engaging in a
debate with them I was appalled to find
that what they had done is essentially
replicate the fundamentalist beliefs of
Christian conservatives in sect with
secular language in secular garb that
they had like the radical Christian
right created a binary worldview of us
in them of good and evil of black and
white they externalize evil in the same
way the Christian Right does evil is not
something within the human heart endemic
to all of us something that we must all
struggle against but evil is a force out
there that once we eradicate will allow
us to advance forward morally if not to
a perfect society to a more perfect
society this kind of utopian vision
wedded to the dangerous belief that
violence can be used to advance this
vision to purify the world is
characteristic of most utopian
movements and these movements have been
the curse of modern society since
probably the Jacobins and France
it goes back of course to the
Enlightenment itself the Enlightenment
was a blessing in many ways a reaction
to the anti intellectualism repression
superstition bigotry of the church but
it was also a curse what the
Enlightenment did is it adopted the
notion of the linear notion of time
which is a product peculiar product
actually of the Hebraic and the
Christian traditions the idea that we
are moving towards redemption or
salvation this is completely foreign in
oriental religions a completely foreign
to the ancient Greeks who believe that
both individual life and societal or
communal life was about birth growth
degeneration decay and death that there
was a cyclical quality to existence but
what the Enlightenment did is it dropped
the wisdom of original sin uh it you
know I think stated probably most
clearly by Augustine in City of God city
of man his great work where he argued
that the perfect society or the the City
of God could only be created by God that
it was incapable of being created by
humankind because we were endemically
flawed the Enlightenment jettisoned this
idea and put their faith in science
rational human beings and knowledge as a
way to advance humankind and create a
more perfect world this belief is
extremely dangerous because it is a
short step as the jacobins proved with
the committee of virtue in the reign of
terror that once you define certain
groups of human beings as impediments to
that progress if you believe that they
are incapable of being
inverted or reformed than they must be
eradicated
and I think the the vast killing
projects of that we saw in the last
century by communists and fascists was
directly tied to that enlightenment
vision the New Atheists argue in some
ways along these lines but what they
have done I think like many utopians is
distort the the very disciplines that
they claim as the basis for their
ideology for example the idea that we
can advance morally that there that
human beings make progressive steps
towards moral improvement is not borne
out empirically there's nothing in human
nature or human history that suggests
that we advanced morally the idea that
evolutionary biology can be used as a
kind of blueprint for human activity is
childish and naive at best let me give
you an example politics for instance is
fitfully in contact with a rational this
is something that Sigmund Freud
understood and allowed Freud to write
his masterpiece civilization and its
discontents which eerily sort of
forecast the self annihilation and
conflagration that gripped Europe during
the Second World War
it's also a misuse of Darwinian science
there's nothing in the origin of the
species that suggests that we are
advancing morally Darwin rights in fact
and I think correctly the opposite that
we are products of irrational behavior
of animal instincts species certainly
accrue mutations of what Darwin is too
good a scientist to ever posit where
that will end up and what they've done
is take evolutionary biology and at
which perhaps can is useful at times as
an
and use it as a kind of blueprint for
human behavior they have essentially
created a definition of religion that
embodies all evil religion is
responsible for violence for
superstition for ignorance and certainly
there is no question that religious
groups have in religious institutions
are culpable of to this charge but this
simplistic view of the world which i
think is very much replicated by the
radical christian right ignores the
complexity and the ambiguity and the
outside forces that go into creating
fanaticism of the idea for instance that
people read the Quran and become a
suicide bomber ignores a the long slow
drip of repression collective
humiliation abuse occupation that go
into creating fanaticism terrorism is
what you do when you don't have what you
use as a weapon to create maximum mayhem
and chaos and murder when you don't have
artillery or planes or cruise missiles
and you know there's no shortage of
studies by Pape and others that go into
explaining the forces that go in to
creating desperate characters who carry
out desperate acts one of the things
that disturbs me most about the radical
Christian Right and the New Atheists is
this self exaltation this elevation of
us above others that the kind of moral
superiority the relegating of other
people to more moral inferior levels the
kinds of things that the New Atheists
for example write about Muslims could be
lifted from the most rabid sermon by a
Christian fundamentalist their political
agenda completely converges and I think
that's not accidental for example Sam
Harris
in his book the end of faith asks us to
consider carrying out a nuclear
first-strike on the Arab world admitting
that this in his words would be a crime
that would kill tens of millions of
people but it may be something that we
have to do given what these people
believe this kind of utopianism this
kind of belief that massive catastrophic
violence will propel the world forward I
think is endemic within American society
the war in Iraq for example is a utopian
project if you take the roughly 10,000
Erebus in this country and by that I
mean people who speak Arabic and have
spent a prolonged period of time in the
Middle East I don't think you could find
could have found more than 10 that
believed invading and occupying Iraq was
a good idea that somehow Iraqis would
greet us as liberators that democracy
would be implanted in Baghdad and spread
outwards throughout the Middle East and
that the oil revenues would pay for
reconstruction this was a non reality
based belief system and it's something
that was embraced by the radical
Christian right by the neo cons and is
embraced by those people who identify
themselves as new atheists what I fear
is that at the core of both of these
movements there is a kind of celebration
of ignorance these people are culturally
and I'm talking about both the radical
Christian Right and the New Atheists
they are culturally historically and
linguistically illiterate they know
nothing about the Middle East and
nothing about religion and they believe
that there is no need to investigate
other ways of being other ways of
believing in other ways of thinking
because they have elevated their own
narrow bourgeois middle-class values to
a highest good and their very particular
values have been
defined as universal values that
everyone out there must either accept or
have shoved down their throat let me
conclude before we have questions by
talking a little bit about religion one
of the things that I found most
frustrating debating the new atheists in
a public forum was their attempt to deal
Ajith amaizing that I come out of my
father was a Presbyterian minister I'm a
graduate from Harvard Divinity School he
was a social activist very involved in
the civil rights movement the anti-war
movement his veteran of World War two
and finally the gay rights movement his
brother his youngest brother my uncle
was gay and my father had a particular
sensitivity to the pain of being a gay
man in America in the 1950s and 60s this
is a real tradition it is embodied in
figures like Dorothy Day William Sloane
coffin Martin Luther King Daniel
Berrigan yet when I when I've debated
Christian fundamentalists even though I
can state before we begin the debate my
own tradition and where I'm coming from
the rest of the debate is filled with
empty cliches about how I am a force for
secular humanism and a godless America
and seeking to destroy the Christian
faith and the family and all the
wonderful values that they claim to
support and it doesn't matter what you
say they keep hammering home with this
kind of jingoistic can't it's of course
the epistemology of television which is
anti thought and that the new atheists
do exactly the same thing so that when I
get up and debate a new atheists I can
say as I do that I don't believe in an
anthropomorphic being that is God I
don't believe in heaven and hell I don't
believe in miracles I fully accept that
there are long passages in the Greek and
Hebrew Bibles that are morally
indefensible I mean the Gospel of John
is filled with raw anti-semitism the
misogyny and homophobia of Paul
axé we're in in Genesis where Yahweh
blesses righteous genocide against the
Egyptians whole passages of Leviticus
Daniel revelation uh and and and I
become within their definition a
defender of superstition in fact at the
summation of the debate at UCLA with Sam
Harris at the end of the debate he
talked about how he felt that it was a
thousand years ago and we were talking
about whether witches exist I don't
believe that witches exist but they
can't argue outside of that definition
of religion and I think that one of the
things that fraud is frustrating is that
they're not only a phenomenally ignorant
of the world especially the Muslim world
that they demonize in the same way that
the Christian Right does demonizing them
is irrational religious hordes the
Christian Right would just change a few
words here and there and call it a
satanic religion led by the Antichrist
the result is the same especially if you
believe that you have a right to employ
violence against these people but they
the new atheists will take the the their
own sort of small narrow definition of
of what it is to be religious and a
definition by the way that I think most
of us find detestable and that no
shortage of great theologians like Carl
Bart have defined or Paul Tillich as a
form of idolatry and and they can never
step outside their parameters they just
as they don't need to investigate or
look at other ways of being other ways
of believing in other ways of thinking
they don't need to read theology and
when when they write about religion it
is essentially the equivalent of me
reading Peterson's field guide to birds
and then writing an attack on biology
you know they they they're quite taken
with their own cleverness for instance a
Hitchens writes that no theologian has
ever asked who created the creator well
any first-year seminar
arian will tell you that numerous
theologians including Aquinas dealt with
the issue of who created the creator and
and that there's no shortage of great
religious thinkers who have in with far
more sophistication absolutely
obliterated of the belief systems
embraced by Christian and most religious
fundamentalists so I think finally you
know this book is a plea for an
understanding of the complexity of the
world around us an understanding of our
own complicity in creating a much of the
violence that is directed against us you
know what is the greatest weapon of mass
terror it is the atomic bomb and that's
how it was designed and that's why it
was dropped on Nagasaki and Hiroshima
which had no military significance in
many ways to send by the way a message
to the Russians and we are the only
nation on earth that's employed it I've
been in Gaza when american-made f-16
fighter jets piloted by Israelis have
dropped 1000 pound iron fragmentation
bombs on refugee camps and I think that
if we don't capture or we are unable to
create empathy we are going to build a
world of apocalyptic extremes to
understand is not to excuse of course
but we are never going to solve the
problems that face us unless we
understand why they're there and how
they're created and begin to build a
world that mitigate the forces that go
into creating fanaticism I mean for
example in the with a radical Christian
right in this country I think the fault
is the disenfranchisement of the
American working class courtesy of
Democratic and Republican
administrations you know the the loss of
hope traveling around the country
especially to former manufacturing
centers like Youngstown Ohio you see
that the end of the
world is not an abstraction to these
people they have been left completely
bereft state and federal assistance has
been slashed there are parts of the
United States that now resemble the
third world we are building a corporate
state and oligarchic system where the
top 1% now controlled more wealth in the
bottom 90% combined and they've lost
hope because they know that the jobs and
much of my own family comes from
working-class mill towns in Maine and
I've seen this directly visited upon
them much of the jobs that made it
possible for a single income to sustain
a family of four or five with benefits
and health insurance they know not only
that they're never coming back but that
they're never coming back for their
children and when you interview as I did
many of the followers in the radical
religious right though stories they tell
would break your heart of terrible
financial distress broken homes sexual
abuse the pro-life in the pro-life
movement I would say probably 80% I
didn't do a survey but of the women I
interviewed it had multiple abortions
the cruelty of this movement that plays
on this despair you know in the in the
pro-life movement they will take women
for a way for weekends a group of
Catholic group called priests for life
and give them dolls and tell them these
were the babies that they killed and
they will have to carry these ball dolls
for the weekend and clothe them and
sleep with them and name them and then
at the end of the weekend offer them up
to God and promised to spend the rest of
their lives fighting against the culture
of death as atonement the manipulation
by the movement is severe and
frightening which is why the only way to
stem the rise of the radical right in
this movement in this country is through
a massive anti-poverty program it is
about Rhian franchising these people
back into American society I think much
of the anger toward liberals is not
misplaced we have
betrayed these people we stood by as
their jobs their livelihood and their
dignity were taken from them and I fear
that as we enter a period of difficulty
that there will be a backlash but it
will be a right-wing backlash it will be
a backlash by people who feel that the
established order has nothing to offer
them
I fear that certainly the New Atheists
are not politically organized they're
not a political threat the way the
radical Christian right is but what I
fear is that they will converge they
will come together to call for a
horrific bloodletting especially if we
suffer when we suffer another terrorist
attack especially then and of course
directed against the Muslim world if
it's deemed that this attack comes from
the Muslim world and I think I also
worry about the six million Muslims who
live within our borders and and this is
a kind of call on the part I think of
certainly the people I'm trying to reach
to abandon utopian visions all ethics
based on utopianism descend into moral
depravity and criminality Iraq is the
perfect example ethics that don't take
in the reality around us a reality that
in the coming decades is going to be
harsh and difficult you know the one of
the things the New Atheists will argue
is that because science and technology
progresses we are progressing without
understanding that science technology
and industry are morally neutral Science
and Technology and industry has
certainly at least for those of us who
live in the eighteen industrialized
nations enhanced life and nurtured life
but an equal measure it is been used to
destroy life too
the environment we are destroying the
very ecosystem that sustains the human
species in dust the industrial age
created industrial warfare and
industrial slaughter we now have the
capacity to kill human beings in numbers
unseen before in human history and the
tools have changed but human nature has
not and I think that unless we give up
utopian visions you know unless we
understand that the morally neutral
discipline of science is not going to
save us I mean this is as self
delusional as a belief that Jesus is
going to descend from the sky and lift
us all into heaven unless we begin to
reject all utopianism x' and begin to
and build an ethic that is based on the
reality around us um then I think it
what it what it does and what utopian
visions intend to do is create a kind of
political and social passivity because
there's a blind faith that forces
greater than you are going to come to
your aid and I think it's very clear
with overpopulation multiple pollutions
the specter of nuclear terrorism that we
as a society have to wake up and we have
to wake up soon because the world
that's that sustains us is in tremendous
danger thank
well we have quite a few questions here
and I want to start with those several
questions that focus on on discourse
your argument is based on the premise
that the world is not simply black and
white yet fundamentalists on both sides
would have us believe that it is as the
divisive mists permeated the political
social and religious discourse so
completely that we can no longer engage
in discussion or compromise and this
questioner asks I'll give you a couple
do you think it's important to pick a
side of faith that atheism or is the
path of undecided the highest road to
take and lastly what this questioner
asks if you have suggestions on how to
discuss these matters with family or
friends who have been pulled into
fundamentalist groups well what is
religion religion like art is an attempt
to deal with the non-rational
that's not irrational non rational those
powerful forces that inform all of our
lives love beauty the search for meaning
our mortality grief alienation these
cannot be empirically measured it's why
Freud said he could never finally write
about love write about sex he couldn't
write about love and religious systems
are human creations God is a human
concept all religious systems are flawed
all of them are finite attempts to deal
with the infinite to deal with those
transcendent forces and the need that
human beings have for the sacred and I
think art and you know in an early
religious life art and religion were not
divorced I think art itself is a
religious ritual certainly an important
ritual
and what art and religion are trying to
do is acknowledge preserve and to a
certain extent explain these forces that
make up a complete human being and I
think that is probably one of the great
failings of the New Atheists and that
they don't distinguish between the non
rational and the irrational I'm
certainly a great admirer of Darwin you
know evolutionary biology is one of the
great leap forwards in our intellectual
tradition I don't find this in conflict
with the religious life the questions of
science are not the questions of
religion science is not there are plural
truths and science the way there is
within human society so I think that the
importance of religion is that it is an
attempt to move us beyond of the
quantity q Malaysian of data or
knowledge and make possible wisdom you
know in the oriental trading Buddhism it
doesn't matter how many sutras you
memorize you will never be wise by
memorizing sutras it is a matter of
understanding those non rational forces
that go into making up human nature and
human society it is about understanding
intuition and that that is finally what
leads to wisdom you know there there are
the Bible has always been read
selectively every religious tradition
does I think one of the other mistakes
the new atheist make is that Dogma is
somehow important dogma has nothing to
do religious dogma has nothing to do
with what people believe that's based on
socio-economic conditions culture
history I mean it you know talking about
all Muslims as if they're the same is is
this is like saying well a Bolivian
Catholic is the
same as a French Catholic because
they're both Catholics anybody who lives
has lived as I have for seven years in
the Middle East understands that a
Turkish Muslim is not the same as a
Sudanese Muslim you know they're colored
by the cultures and traditions and
national characteristics that go into
forming their own community so you know
look at American Catholics I mean Pope
Benedict can issue as many turgid
encyclicals as he wants about birth
control or anything else and everyone
ignores him and that's true in every
religious tradition so the notion that
somehow you look at the Koran you find
passages and they're there that are you
know repugnant morally repugnant and it
therefore you understand Islam is
childish in terms of dealing with a
fundamentalist I think that we have to
be I can't argue with somebody who has
been seduced by a non reality based
world you you you know you can lay down
all the evidence that you want showing
that the world was not created six
thousand years ago and you know
dinosaurs were did not roam the earth
with humankind and they will dismiss it
as sort of corrupted by secular humanism
which they have defined as a rival
ideology I think that we are far better
addressing the core issues that drive
people into the arms of this movement
which is health care decent jobs federal
and state assistance good public schools
essentially recreating a society where
people have hope because without hope
you are driven into the arms of
demagogues and charlatans and was there
another question I missed there I don't
know it was sorry
several questioners would like a little
bit more understanding of the term New
Atheism is New Atheism a movement and if
so what are its intentions aren't the
atheists just arguing against a rush
dogma and is the term New Atheists
really appropriate based upon the idea
that only now in human history can an
atheist speak freely without risk of
death and lastly can you give examples
of New Atheists
other than Hitchens and Harris other
suggestions Dawkins Daniel Dennett
Lawrence Krauss well I'm very aware that
being a self-proclaimed atheist even in
American society is difficult I don't
think anybody could run for president
announcing that they were an atheist or
they could but you know they would be
you know that you have candidates
falling all over themselves to tell us
what great Christians they are I think
that that this movement is very
different from traditional atheism you
know there's certainly nothing
intrinsically more about being a
believer or a non-believer many people
of great moral probity and courage have
led exemplary lives without engaging in
religious ritual you know finding
meaning in religious structures or using
religious language just as many
important religious figures have used
their religious authority to sanction
cruelty bigotry intolerance and violence
so you know I'm very careful at the
beginning of the book to acknowledge
that you know that this is you know
people can find a moral core or a life
of meaning outside of religion and
that's just a fact and it's I think part
of my frustration with many religious
movements including liberal movements is
that they it comes with this sort of
notion that their honorary sinners you
know there's a kind of endemic
self-righteousness
which is totally unwarranted what
terrifies me about this movement the new
atheist movement is that they have
swallowed exactly the same kind of
hubris they've L of
American exceptionalism and they've
reduced the world to a cartoonish a
childish vision I mean they never talk
about globalization for instance as a
force that creates suffering and poverty
you know everything everything evil is
embodied in religion they have created a
pseudoscience that is as a delusional as
the pseudoscience created by the
Christian Right to explain creationism
I'll give you an example which is
Dawkins idea of memes memes are
supposedly AI cultural ideas that are
passed on from one generation to another
and if we can control memes or ideas we
can eradicate people who are led down
the path into superstitious religion
well there's a word for that it's called
totalitarianism you know the the idea
that memes which he equates with genes
is not science it is a leap from science
into scientism or the cult of science
and all utopian movements use the cult
of science to justify unrealistic and
fantastic utopian visions you know the
Nazis did it you know with eugenics
Hitler was sending people off to try and
breed human beings with apes to create
oversized warriors you had it under the
Communists where they would rejected
Jewish science Mendel's genetics and
Einstein Einstein's physics you know and
and I think that Dawkins although he's
British and doesn't embrace the kind of
raw imperialism and Eric well Hitchens
is British so I'm not quite sure why he
embraces it but he is different I mean
there are differences and those are
acknowledged in the book EAL Wilson is
you know a humanist but I think he
finally falls into this belief system
this dangerous belief system that we can
morally advance that human beings can be
improved upon and I guess in many ways
you know at its core that's what I'm
arguing about that you know we have
really ultimately not
thing to fear from people who don't
believe in God but we have a great deal
to fear from people who don't believe in
sin this questioner is a Muslim American
and says as a Muslim American it seems
to me that Islam is the least radical
religion in America today why is that
and beyond
America's borders does your argument
about fundamentalist views apply only to
the United States or is it equally true
in other countries and other societies
how Universal is the discord and
disconnect between fundamentalists on
both sides in terms of Islam in American
society I think it proves the point that
I was trying to make earlier that all
religious systems are colored by the
culture in which they thrive and adapt
to that culture if they're going to
remain alive religion and belief is
changes over time and you know the the
and you can see that when you study the
history of religious movements in terms
of fundamentalist movements Cara
Armstrong I think is written quite
thoughtfully on this she argues first of
all that fundamentalism religious
fundamentalism is a distinctly modern
phenomena it goes it talks about moral
purity and tradition but it is an
outgrowth of modernity dislocation loss
of identity I think all of this is true
fundamentalists bear far more in common
with each other
irregardless of the religious tradition
they come out of than they do often with
people around them in their own
tradition and you find for instance in
the Middle East that many Islamic
fundamentalists are particularly at war
with other Muslims who they feel are not
religiously pure in the same way that
you find the Christian Right at war with
people such as myself who they would
dismiss as to use their language as
nominal Christians so yes fundamentalism
is apocalyptic utopian and they play off
of each other
when I covered the war in the former
Yugoslavia you soon learned that
slobodan milosevic
in Serbia needed Franjo Tudjman in
Croatia in the same way that a who tomar
in Jerusalem needs Hamas and Gaza or
that jour the way George Bush needs
al-qaeda and look I am not naive about
al-qaeda and their desire to carry out
another terrorist strike but they their
capacity and their threat has been blown
way out of proportion I mean one of the
things that both the Christian Right and
the new atheist do is build ideological
systems that one are in the service of
their own power and secondly are fear
based and they need to create an
engendered feelings of fear in order to
drive people forward into a belief
system that embraces this frightening
vision of turning other human beings
into abstractions human beings who no
longer have human qualities of
compassion and love and and grief and
suffering but are simply embody hatred
and violence essentially it's a process
of dehumanization and it's something
that both the New Atheists do especially
towards Muslims and the Christian Right
does two questions here that ask about
your view of history one is I've always
been a bit uncomfortable with the quote
attributed to Martin Luther King the arc
of history is long but it bends towards
justice you would reject that view
questioner asks and the other is a
person recalling a seminary professor
noted the Christian idea of history is
linear and suggesting that communism was
in fact a Christian history he went on
to say that his idea was that history is
just one darn thing after another
I love Martin Luther King who was pretty
steeped in Reinhold Niebuhr you know and
had I think a you know a pretty good
grasp on human history and human nature
look
human societies and human individuals
can make moral advances certainly but
they also make moral reverses and I
don't think that when we look back
through recorded human history we can
argue that that it is morally linear
that we are advancing towards a
perfected moral state you know I love
Samuel Beckett actually think that in
many ways Samuel Beckett is probably the
most authentically religious writer of
the 20th century Beckett unlike Joyce
understood that in the end all we have
is each other
certainly he understood the moral
neutrality of the universe the
strangeness and absurdity of it all the
fictional narratives we tell ourselves
about ourselves and others and yet there
are incredible moments and you know what
I think of one in Waiting for Godot
where Vladimir and Estragon every time
they hear a noise offstage that they
feel is threatening they hold hands and
walk to the other side of the stage as
for me a profoundly religious moment
anyone who has read the book of
ecclesiastes you know that is a book
that could have been authored by Beckett
the notion that the Bible was ever
created as a consistent document is just
not historically accurate in Greek it's
called table biblia that means little
books and you went in and pulled out
scrolls and if you thought it was
garbage you put it back in and that's
what all believers in all religions do
today so that you know you search for
passages that speak to you that speak to
the human condition that imparted truth
and you turn away from those that don't
it's called discernment
it's called moral judgment you know that
the Bible was never created as a kind of
handbook for how to live your life you
know and and when you I think one of the
things I found so frustrating with both
the New Atheists and the Christian Right
is how biblically illiterate they are
on a more practical side I guess does
your argument extend to the use of
torture and the willingness of the US
government for example to forego civil
liberties and values enshrined in the
Constitution
how have the extremes of religion and
science contributed to our willingness
to engage in such behavior and whatever
happened to the separation of church and
state well this is of course what's
frightens me that it's been so severely
eroded you know the last seven years of
the Bush administration has seen a
deadly assault not only on the rule of
law at home but international law you
know the the occupation of Iraq under
post Nuremberg Laws is a crime of
aggression we have no right to be in
Iraq it never threatened us it never
threatened any of our allies and even
within the context of this campaign with
both the Democratic and Republican
candidates we still have a discussion
about the terms of the occupation we run
offshore penal colonies where we torture
you know there's a long Harrison
Hitchens our you know ardent
propagandists for both pre-emptive war
and for torture Harris has a long
passage in his book defending the use of
torture now I've spent a lot of time in
countries where they do torture and when
you are forced to torture people you
have an intelligence system that doesn't
work torture is a very inefficient means
of attaining information Harris quotes
Dershowitz his absurd idea about the
ticking time bomb there's a nuclear
device about to go off and you have a
terrorist he knows where it is and you
have a right to torture them well of
course he can't give us a historical or
legal precedent for such a case because
there isn't one
the only thing torture does is create a
class of sadists and murderers who seep
outwards into a society and start
torturing in larger and larger and
ever-increasing numbers we have American
citizen
Jose Padilla who have been denied habeas
corpus stripped of their rights declared
an enemy combatant and rendered a
vegetable you used to say about the
Gestapo that they broke bones and the
East German secret police the Stasi
broke Souls where the Stasi we break
Souls it's far more efficient and we
have employed large numbers of people in
the scientific certainly the
psychological community to develop that
into a pernicious and dangerous artform
and if we don't begin you know for those
of us who care about the democratic
state and the rights enshrined in the
Constitution the separation of church
and state the check of power on an
imperial presidency if we don't begin to
stand up in it with a kind of militancy
against this abuse we are going to slide
towards a frightening despotism I
believe that we are probably one and at
best two terrorist attacks away from a
police state another question along
these lines and then we'll move on to a
different protect do you think that the
unwillingness to see an appointed an
opponents point of view has contributed
to the u.s. administration's propensity
to use force engage in war and use
violence does this come from society
or does it come from politics itself it
comes from the inability to have empathy
it comes from the inability to stand in
the shoes of the other to grasp the
historical precedence the fears a
cultural milieu that goes into creating
the reaction of those who oppose you and
you cannot build any kind of a community
or any kind of a dialogue unless you
possess that capacity for empathy and
that capacity is only achievable by
having spent considerable amount of time
in that culture and transmitting
accurately the reality of that culture
to an American public
now unfortunately the press has broken
down in this country certainly on
television I don't own a television it's
become about entertainment it is you
know foreign correspondents are sort of
going the way of blacksmiths we are a
country that is increasingly ignorant
and and by the way increasingly reviled
wedded to tremendous power and I and and
we are adopting on both extremes the
religious extreme as well as the new
atheist stream a fundamentalist mindset
which is the danger because those people
in the center which i think is most of
us who would like to create a communal
ties beyond our borders are going to be
drowned out by these apocalyptic
visionaries especially in a moment of
fear so you know it's it's sort of the
late Roman Republic and we've invested
as a culture our emotional life in the
arena which has poisoned civil and
political discourse
you know the very epistemology of
television which is about cliches or as
robert jay lifton would call them
thought terminating cliches a constitute
discourse or what passes for discourse
but of course this kind of discourse the
shouting of cliches back and forth is an
ability to shut down any any real
dialogue and I am terrified that you
know that we just won't be able to cope
with the world around us because we
won't understand it well I think you've
answered this one but just just to add
to it why are the New Atheists so proud
of their ignorance and what role do you
think the media plays and in the
strength of their numbers and another
follow on how should responsible
statesmen deal with religious
constituents and religious people in
other
well the you know the New Atheists you
know but I think both the belief systems
of the New Atheists and the Christian
Right are really at their core about
self exaltation
that's the attractiveness of it so that
when you have a discussion you know when
I I debated Charles McVitie a head of
the evangelical Association in Canada at
the University of Toronto and he sort of
bussed in several of his own supporters
all night long he just shouted
derogatory cliches about how I want to
destroy the Christian nation and every
time one of these cliches he spat out
one of these cliches
he got arise from the crowd and from his
supporters in the crowd and the same
thing happened when I debated the New
Atheists every time they would say
something demeaning about religion it
got a rise from the crowd it was
irrelevant what I said and I think that
the rage that I felt from many in the
Christian right after I wrote my book
American fascists the Christian Right in
the war in America is similar to the
rage that has been expressed to be my
many atheists because what I'm attacking
is their form of self-righteousness and
I'm telling them look you know you're
just as messed up as the rest of us and
and I think that that the emotionalism
on the part of both of these groups
stems precisely from from this hubris
and arrogance okay so let's let's come
back to beliefs do you believe in a
living God with whom one can have a
personal relationship and if so how does
this impact your approach to atheists no
I don't you know I was in sorry AVO
during the war when it was being hit
with two thousand shells a day constant
sniper fire
four to five dead a day two dozen
wounded a day 45 foreign reporters were
killed in Sarajevo scores were wounded
2,000 children died in that city I do
not believe that God had a plan for me
to survive my life is not worth more
than the lives of those children who
were killed I think that that kind of
narcissism which infects the
industrialized world is possible because
we do live in zones of safety but I have
not spent my life in zones of safety I
survived the war in Sarajevo because I
had a $100,000 armored Land Rover and
$5,000 worth of body armor and
bodyguards I understand the cold reality
and the horrible neutrality of the world
around us I don't believe in a personal
God I don't believe in an
anthropomorphic God I don't believe in
heaven or hell you know I think
Dostoevsky got it right what is hell
hell is the inability to love hell is
that complete isolation where one can no
longer connect with another look you
know religious systems are important as
metaphors you know when Freud wanted to
write about the internal dynamics of the
human psyche he went back to the Greek
myths not because he thought the Greek
myths were literally true but because
the Greek myths expressed a truth about
the human condition the writers of the
book of Genesis knew nothing about the
process of creation they thought the
earth was flat but they did know
something about the purpose of creation
and I think that we ignore these
religious myths at our peril you know it
is like Lynne Cheney talking about
novels not being true and therefore not
important
this is a kind of pedantic childish
view of the world that precludes the
possibility of wisdom I don't think you
can understand fully the human condition
or at least give a vocabulary to it
without reading works like Proust or
Beckett or Shakespeare I mean the list
goes on and on and on and the same is
true for great religious thinkers
Erasmus Agustin Reinhold Niebuhr you
know neighbors first grade book moral
man and immoral society didn't have one
Bible verse in it at all it was a social
criticism and that's what he certainly
was informed by a religious tradition
Paul Tillich's great work the first book
one of the first books banned by the
Nazis was called the Socialists dilemma
the Nazis went to the warehouses when
they took power and seized it it never
appeared until after the war he was the
first non-jewish professor blacklisted
and denied a university post anywhere in
Germany because he understood that a
religious or a belief system that was
not intimately engaged with culture at
that moment he called it taking time
seriously was irrelevant and people who
stand on moral principle and they can do
that certainly outside of religious
structures have become our powerful
forces in society you know if everyone
sat around in 1940 in France and said
well you know we better work with Vichy
because it's practical because nothing
can happen with the resistance
where would the soul of France have been
and I think that you know for me
religiosity is is a way of being it is
it's not it is one you know where one
accepts mystery one accepts our
inability finally to ever understand and
I think that that is you know repeated
throughout both the Greek and the Hebrew
Bibles I mean you know when Moses asks
God who is he says I am Who I am or you
will know me when you know me and and I
think that's true I think that though
those who fail to fully explore the
religious impulse the ability to connect
with those transcendent forces are not
fully human so we've come really to our
the last set of questions and I want to
bring you back to science for a moment
and ask are we revisiting in the 21st
century the debate over evolution and
does intelligent design play into the
hands of those who would apply more
extreme opposition to religious views
and lastly how might this this
discussion and about fundamentalist
positions apply to debates on climate
change well intelligent design or
creationism is a frightening ideology
because it's not true pseudoscience and
when we as a culture elevate creationism
or intelligent design to the level of
evolutionary biology what we're really
saying is lies or true you are you can
believe whatever you want to believe by
the time you put intelligent design and
an evolutionary biologist on the same
platform you've lost
Hannah Aaron understood this very well
in origins of totalitarianism the first
thing totalitarian movements do is cut
them off from the real world they wrap
them in the cocoon of a non reality
based belief system a system where lies
are true and everything is seen through
a frightening ideological lens that's
what Christian radio and television does
and there are tens of millions of
Americans who get their news their
entertainment their spiritual guidance
their health and beauty tips
all through this distorted prism so I'm
a fierce opponent of creationism I think
the universities in this country have
failed us by not going to war against it
they have been passive
and I worry that when we elevate and
give respectability to intelligent
design it's the equivalent of giving
respectability to the pseudoscience of
eugenics uses scientific garbage
scientific language to propagate an
untruth that whose goal is to support an
ideology not dispassionate and honest
intellectual inquiry well on behalf of
the World Affairs Council of Northern
California and the Graduate theological
Union please join me in thanking mr.
hedges